you
it's going to be crazy for sure alright
here we go
waiting for 29 players and let's get
ready to roll many thanks again to those
of you that are in the chat and those of
you who are also on Twitter thank you
for the retweet of the link that I just
put out there that's the status update
for Zog Zog rush chess is what I called
it oh my goodness let's go here let's go
alright move fast you only have two
minutes to come up with something ah
let's get this in maybe I should have
done this first oh man I know that it's
going to be far easier to play on the
white side I'm looking to capture
through on this let's take two pawns out
for every minor piece just drop all the
way back oh let's do this I guess oh I
don't know what I want to do here oh boy
I'm getting squeezed this is not turning
out good pawn push can I really get that
yeah minute-forty
hmm I guess I take I gotta break this
open somehow I got to get behind enemy
lines take their probably took too soon
h4 going to be played let's do this my
queen is now going to be hit ouch oh man
okay I got a smash through I think this
move would have been important or good
you go after that pawn
oh man this is not going to turn out
good oh man oh man it's so much easier
to play with the pawns I know it is
alright I got to try something pac-man
mode they only have a minute so you
could win on time let's go here oh boy I
think I got a take just so my rook can
see I want to get these furthest
advanced pawns not an easy task
okay let's say
that guy ooh they're giving me free
stuff love that
let's take here maybe I should have
taken there I could take twice here and
get this pawn pac-man mode engaged
I'm scooping up these pawns now okay I
have control oh man
okay let's take him out let's do this
hun push this working - be careful still
have to be a little careful let's just
give that up I could do this my queen
will be able to track down these right
they're not going anywhere
my queen is enough to pick up all of
these boom boom almost successful with
getting everything right here and then
takes finally back to tournament wow
that felt like a marathon no I don't
want the pieces I want to play with the
pawns
ah man these are so difficult to cope
with
ah pawn tsunami this is basically what I
did with that last video I do with the
rook pawns coming up here I guess take
like this and then Knight here looking
for sacrifice on this square actually I
could do
and the night here stops this for the
moment so Queen takes pawn is available
oh boy uh I'm not going to take let them
take me maybe oh boy
night here looking for sacrifices on
this square my goodness this is painful
well it's a very painful game okay I
want to smash through I gotta get rid of
this pawn he needs to go it's official
he needs to go but here come more puns
okay let's do this and then take here I
have a pawn around at least okay how can
I break through I need to know how I can
break through here stop this on push I
will take twice and then take here I
guess put some pressure here all right
let's take with this my rook is
activated let's do this
and then I guess King up rook over smash
through here that's a way to get to the
back rank and take the pawn here they
have 50 seconds all right let's smash
through Oh
here now my queen gets down here unless
they block it off no they didn't I get
to sneak in oh boy let's take here um
here my queen gonna be out of play let's
see I could drop my rook back come all
the way back here Queen takes pawn here
is what I want right ooh let's try this
I think I need my I'm not getting get
made it am i it can't happen it
definitely can happen oh I'm going to
give that up
okay that's important I want to get
these guys for sure get rid of this guy
okay now my queen is free to do some
other stuff let's take here let's take
this go after these pawns now all right
take take this pawn look at this how do
i how do i combat this got attacked
attack the base get rid of him take care
okay I have this under control
or do I I need my king over here to stop
these guys now I could do it rook takes
pawn rook takes here okay takes and then
takes here back to tournament wow this
is too much to handle I want to play
with the pawns yes there we go had to
happen sometime right let's see how my
opponent deals with this oh man oh let's
go with this guy and let's keep pushing
up just a little bit
oh let's take and then do this they're
gonna sack yeah okay let's take like
this and then I guess this move gotta go
fast
be careful of this I definitely want to
do this this is a nice nice pond to have
I think and now this is really well
reinforced
let's get these Center pounds up a
little bit I was ready to drop that pond
hmm let's do this
here that night's a pain all right
thinking a sack no I get to reinforce
that now okay get to take let's do this
I guess um just do that um I don't know
what I should do here oh I see what
they're ready to do they could sack here
let's see if they do it no now I get
this move in and then I could push as
soon as the Queen leaves okay I'm kind
of out of moves in a way
um mm-hmm
I don't have any time I can't even think
through 40 seconds ah gotta get this
going I guess gotta get that night out
of there I'm dropping some stuff and I
think I need to get going with this guy
in the center ok these pawns are inching
forward here they're very dangerous
support that that's a free pond isn't it
I get to do this now and here next pawn
push pawn push let's do that I guess oh
here 17 seconds oh that's the biggest
thing that's definitely the biggest
thing here next pawn push next the
knight is hit pawn push let's do that
pawn push here that rooks very active oh
I could have taken their queen why did I
take their Queen yeah I missed that I
could have taken their Queen I only have
6 seconds
ah I just gotta make any old move oh I'm
getting this for seconds oh now they
have that ah there go all my pawns
oh they got all my pawns back to
tournament
oh what a marathon I gotta go faster oh
I thought it was like the side with the
pieces who really had to do a lot of
thinking but I turned out to do a lot of
thinking in the early stage with the
pawns there yeah okay gotta go faster I
have the Queen I had their Queen at one
point I missed that okay lesson learned
you got to move faster you got to move a
lot faster let's go here get this pawn
up there let's take here there and then
here oh okay
give me that but they're wiping me out
over here let's do this
what's the bishop gonna do here here
okay I'm gonna gain some tempos against
the King I'm gonna I'm gonna stay ahead
on the clock - I'm gonna try at least
bishops dead let's take that let's get
this guy going and I guess here alright
I got upon who's two steps away I'm
going to try and connect him with my be
pawns on takes pawn takes let's get
rollin with him so I just bypassed that
guy here
let's do that I capture they get to my
back rank
let's get him rolling oh why didn't I
see this okay they could enter back here
now I some pretty far advanced pawns huh
they gotta be careful careful now
rook here rook upon here ah let's get
this guy marching maybe I could get this
pot up here this is a nice pond chain ok
this is gonna be super strong and have a
trio of pawns very soon ah they're out
of play
trio of pawns pawn push here's deadly
night there chase him away first give a
check even pawn push and now I get to do
this and this is gonna be winning I got
a queen I got a queen check in a lot of
pawns as backup I got a lot of funds is
backup and then more pawns are ready to
clean here another queen is on board
you could have 37 36 Queens another
Queen I don't even have to watch out for
my king I don't have to watch out for my
king why is that you don't even have a
king where's the me back to tournament
they're down on time whoo man we're at
the halfway point okay I don't even know
where I stand here ah not well on the
standings I'm not even on the I'm not
even on the list
you didn't make the list there okay yeah
that loss didn't help right you lose a
game it does not help okay gonna sack
there twice huh okay let's get this guy
rolling and let's get this guy up here
next maybe let's do this first
where's their night going who the rook
isn't over here now so I'm gonna look to
play on the h-file I'll take him out
let's do this they're getting they're
getting squeezed over here they're in
some big trouble they're in a giant knot
let's come over here take towards the
center I want to free up this pawn to
get rolling oh oh here come a lot of
pawns that's a check and look out
because ooh this King is keeping
pressure here huh that's an interesting
idea
I didn't realize that let's get these
guys up a little bit more a little bit
more inch by inch okay let's get this in
um let's do this
all right fork Oh got a hang onto that
for this advanced pawn
I get to connect this I want to do this
move if allowed it's not allowed let me
take that bishop I guess we'll take here
pawn push pawn push here let's defend
that pawn 58 seconds let's defend here
can go over here now
where's their King going pawn push let
go
these pawns are so dangerous look at
their kid lose King the king could turn
into pac-man not just the Queen look at
that King he's hunting them down Wow
Pandu Oh
let's get rolling with this guy let's do
this and then pawn push after Queen
takes uh-oh
look at this pawn chain 42 seconds pawn
push next this is definitely winning
isn't it yeah this is big trouble now
this is game over 11 minutes remain
they're not going to get very many games
in you just have to watch out for my
king safety I'm going after I'm going
after the king check Queen trade Queen
trade
oh let's see if the King could survive
you got a lot of Queens here get a lot
of Queens let's give a check and then
another check that's game over back to
tournament ten minutes remain where am I
13th okay number 13 here
whoo I wouldn't have been a that far off
from 13th even if I uh
even if I won that wasn't that big of a
swing was it I could have taken there
twice right oh okay oh I will gladly
invest two minor pieces there let's drop
back boy this is a lot of pawns to deal
with Oh
let's try this I'm getting squeezed I
got a sack I got a open stuff up here
take here all these pawns are squeezing
me oh boy I'm getting so squeezed oh man
I'm getting really squeezed here wow I
can't look at this pond what a beast huh
what ooh a gap a little gap in the what
am I trying to say ah can I get this guy
they're not gonna let me do that just
support him right yeah what do I got now
nothing oh let's try this
get this guy whoo that was big that was
a serious pun gone ah the Queen is
entering now I have good control very
good control this game this position is
cut in half now let's take their yeah I
have really good control now
everything's under control minute 40
about even on time they resigned back to
tournament yeah that pond
I forget on what square it was but that
one really close to my king scared me
one two three four five six games are in
how many games do I have I'm in seventh
I only have 1200 Kay let's try this
let's challenge these guys here probably
just one two three more games most okay
let's get some exchanges here this is uh
this is a bit much here this hoard chess
tournament it's exhausting it's more
exhausting than I would have thought um
here I guess takes Queen takes pawn push
okay let's do that put some pressure
here just gonna reinforce it guess if
they don't I'm going to take here okay
I'm gonna get two pawns here two pawns
for the minor piece I'm into thirty less
than a minute thirty
whoo okay let's chop this guy up and do
what next I guess take here and then I
don't know here oh and then here okay
this is opening up I haven't I didn't
have to invest too much material to have
this position open up let's go here
looking for a sack on this square let's
take here first and then take with my
queen less than a minute for my opponent
here where can I still break through a
pawn push probably yes let's get that in
and then sacrifice on this square h2 on
takes rook takes and then form a battery
here smash through on h2 they're
bypassing that okay I can take take here
and then get back here now pawn push
Queen here let's try this on takes Queen
here pawn takes pawn push and I'm
breaking through thirty Seconds okay my
Bishop is behind enemy lines maybe I
should have taken here doesn't matter 22
seconds
20 seconds should've taken with the
night take the pond yeah they're not
they're not coordinated now they're -
they're not together
to give up these guys Bishop takes pawn
let's go with that one okay they're just
throwing pawns now they didn't have any
time back to tournament they resigned
fifth I have sixteen twenty eight twenty
twenty twenty sixteen can I try for
second place you know what I might need
to try to do if I have the pawns I'm
gonna try to go into berserk mode if I
get a win I would get five points I
think instead of four that's certain on
that but okay five minutes remain yeah
you know I have to shoot for that I have
to play this next one with just a minute
hopefully I have the pawns
I'd much rather play with the pawns
apparently everybody's still going at it
there's 74 players who are here um I
think I still have to try it this is
crazy
I have a minute berserk now I just have
to try to smash through very very quick
one minute to capture 36 points it's not
happening it's definitely not happening
yeah but I will try I will try
definitely okay that's a step in the
direction of maybe being successful I
mean it's getting kicked around let's
try that well they didn't take my knight
even realize that so take care my queen
has to go pacman mode oh my queen is
getting active at a very early stage in
the game let's open up this file
there's a lot of ponds to capture in one
minute oh man okay that's helpful him
next
unless this move okay the furthest
advance ponds I want to get rid of okay
I should be able to do this 37 seconds I
mean here just mop up these guys gotta
go fast yeah I should have this I think
they're playing too much on time yet the
furthest advance pawns the king is an
excellent defender yeah I should I'm
going to get this this is plenty of time
now my queen got really active like
really active take that pawn 22 seconds
and let's take this one next and then
this one got it with some time to spare
back to tournament where does that put
me 21 okay um I'm not going to go
berserk in this one I'm just going to
try to play regular this is going to be
the last game and I think I could try to
get second let's do that with check and
then get up here
all right let's push this King around a
little bit let's get him rolling okay
enter here but oh that can't be right
this is going to be real tough I think
for my opponent
look at these ponds oh boy these ponds
are definitely menacing allow me get
this in oh boy oh boy I could do that
let's get this guy up reinforce this
central mass of ponds here d4 I'll take
that this here just so she doesn't get
active I'm not going to take that just
yet still not going to take it then take
me and then I'll recapture takes I take
like this I don't want to allow the
Queen right here and divert the bishop
away let's support this pond so I could
do this next now I'll take and support
this pond oh boy this is going to be
tricky let's see the sack let's give
this check all right I have to weigh
which ponds are okay to give away and
which ones are not they only have less
than a minute
let's check um ooh
Oh check and then check here I'm getting
a queen oh oh that was cool all right so
now this is Gigi definitely these puns
are too much for one king to handle here
we go let's get a lot of queens on board
oh did the tournament end return to
tournament Oh had already ended I didn't
realize I was so focused on the game it
ended before that one would even have
registered I don't know how close it
even was I would have got third I guess
if I won all right
um did anybody have a squeaky-clean
performance here top was thirty one
thirty one twenty eighth twenty four
twenty four twenty three twenty one is
where I was at nineteen sixteen let's
see who else played and let's see along
the way if anybody had in a
squeaky-clean performance no a goose egg
here goose egg there are a lot of goose
eggs except for this guy nice is this
the guy that I played I might have
played him I'm not sure yeah that's it
that's a really good result there no
losses here's another one with no losses
let's see who else played in this get an
idea all right yeah how many uh 75
people took part in this I don't know if
I'm ever gonna do it again
that's too much that was too much for
chess within 30 minutes I think I think
it's maybe okay in small doses but not
that much within 30 minutes it's a bit
much
all right whoo I am a bit exhausted I
must say
you